وقليل المزيد معي في الاسود وازاميل خالد
الاغرابلي محرر محرر الشؤون الوضع في
فرنسا اهلا بك يا خالد خالد لماذا تعلن
فرنسا في هذا التوقيت بالذات عن ارزال
ارسال هذه الدبابات الخفيفه لك
ربما يكون هذا نوع من الاستعداد لما يسميه
الخبراء معركه الربيع الجميع يعلم ان
الروس وبدعوا في تنظيم خطوط دفاعيه وتحدث
عن اخطاء التركيبات في الشهور الماضيه
وانهم يصححون هذه الاخطاء والجماعي يعلم
ايضا ان الروس ان الروسيا السعدون لهجوم
في المرحله المقبله ربما يكون في نهايه
اثار مارس همم والاكرانيون يعلمون ذلك وهم
ايضا يستعدون الهجوم لكنهم الان بسبب
الظروف المناخيه يجدون صعوبه
ويريدون ربما كل طرف يستعد لما سيحدث في
الاشهر القليله لكن الاوكرانيين يواجهون
صعوبه كبيره
مواجهه المدرعات والدبابات الروسيه ومن
هنا تاتي اهميه ارسال هذه الدبابات
الخفيفه الفرنسيه الاوكرانيون طلبوا كثيرا
بالدبابات ثقيله همم لكن همم كان هناك
خشيه لدى الغرب من ارسال دبابات ثقيله حتى
لا تستفز روسيا وتم الاعتماد على مثل هذه
الدبابه الفرنسيه الخفيفه هي دبابه قديمه
همم تسير على عجلات همم فعاله حتى وان
كانت قديمه والان جيشيه فرنسيه يحاول
تغيير هذه الدبابه وادخل همم الدبابه اخرى
مكانها لكنها فعاله فعاله لانها سرعتها
تصل الى نحو 80 كم في الساعه همم قادر على
ان تكون مستقله في الحركه اللي نحو
الثمانيه 100 كيلو متر وربع معك اكثر
قليلا ومدفعها ايضا يساعدها على ما يسميه
الخبراء الحروب القريبه اي انها تستطيع
مواجهه الدبابات عن قرب وبالتالي بمدفع
105 ملي متر هذا يساعدها على مواجهه
الدبابات الروسيه في نفس الوقت امريكيون
رئيس الامريكي يتحدث عن انه اا يتم بحث
ارسال همم مضارع امريكيه من نوع برادلي
هذه المضارع الامريكيه لا تتمتع بنفس
المدفع همم
تتمتع هي بتحمل مدفع رشاش بالاضافه الى
صواريخ اا تستهدف الدبابات وبالتالي
المضارع الامريكيه ان وفق الامريكيون على
ارسال هي ايضا سرعته ربما نحو 60 كم في
الساعه لكن يمكن ان تصاحب القوات
الاوكرانيه تستطيع حمل سته جنود للقيام
استطلاع للقيام بهم مواجهه بمشاه الروسيه
همم المدفع رشاش يسمح لها بمواجهه القوات
القوات المشاه وايضا صواريخ المحمله عليها
تسمح لها بمواجهه الدبابات والانظمه
الليليه التي عليها تساعدها على اكتشاف
المدرعات الروسيه هذه الاسلحه تساعد ليست
بالحداثه وبالقوه التي كان يتمناها
الاوكرانيون لكن في النهايه من الممكن ان
تساعد الاوكرانيين على اي
مقبله في فصل الربيع طيب خالد يبدا هناك
رساله روسيه من وراء نشر صواريخ فرض صوتيه
ما هي هذه الرساله
الرساله هنا تختلف الروس لا يرسلون او لا
ينشرون سلاح همم قديم الروسي يريدون ان
يقولوا للولايات المتحده ولغرب الذي يدعم
اوكرانيا انكم تتعاملون مع دوله عظمى دوله
عظمى تملك احد همم احدث الاسلحه في العالم
وهي الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه لا تملكها فقط
وانما تدخلها الخدمه وهي من الممكن ان
تستعملها في هذه الحرب وبالتالي ان كان
يمكن هناك اراده سياسيه لاستخدام سلاح
بهذه الحداثه وهذه القوه التدميريه لان
هذا صاروخ قادر حتى على حمل وبوس نوويه
هذا معناه انه ربما من الافضل ان تقف على
الحرب عند هذه عند هذا الحد ونلجا الى
المفاوضات وليس ربما مصادفه ان يخرج
الرئيس البروتين الان ليقول انه مستعد لت
مع اوكرانيا بشرط ان تقبل الوضع الجديد
يعني انت ضم روسيا لاربعه مناطق همم
اوكرانيا يعني يريد ان يفرض ويكسب يجسد
سياسيا محققه على الارض عسكريا من خلال
التاكيد على صوره الدوله العظمى التي تملك
اسلحه حديثه لماذا يتحدث عن صوره اكبر من
اوكرانيا اولا هذا صاروخ سيركن او زيركن
همم لم ينشر على الحدود الاوكرانيه انما
حمل على فرقاطه حامل الصواريخ حديثه دخلت
الخدمه قبل ايام وهي تقوم برحله في المحيط
الاطلسي والبحر المتوسط لتظهر قدره روسيا
على مستوى العالم وليس فقط على حرب
اوكرانيا وهي ليست في حاجه مثل صاروخ بهذه
القدرات في اوكرانيا نحن نتحدث عن صاروخ
فرد صوتي يعني صاروخ يستطيع ان يضرب على
بعض 1,000 كم سرعته تصل الى احد 10,000
كيلو متر في الساعه الروس يقولون انه
صاروخ مخفي بما انه هناك طبق من بلازما
على هذا الصاروخ تمنع الاجهزه الرادار على
رصده همم بغض النظر عن هذه النقطه هذه
المعلومات نظريه من الجانب الروسي ينتظر
ان نرى الى اي مدى هي دقيقه منح العمليه
لكن المعروف بشكل عام رشيد عن الصواريخ
الفارس صوتيه انها صواريخ سرعتها لا تسمح
للاجهزه المنظومات الدفاع الجوي المعروفه
حاليا بان تتصدى لها لانها سريعه للغايه
لان الاتجاه الذي تسلكه ليس بمنحنى بال
صواريخ البالستيه العاديه وانما قادره على
المناوره وبالتالي لا يعرف عن منظومات
دفاع جوي تستطيع ان تتصدى لها يعني
الروسيه يريد ان يقولوا لي الولايات
المتحده للغرب نحن نملك سلاح لا تستطيعون
مواجهته حامل على راس قادر على حمل رؤوس
نبويه وقدره على الوصول الى نحو 1,000
كيلو متر طبعا بعد كثيرا من اوكرانيا
بسرعه ربما انتم لم عدوا بعض لمواجهتي
وبالتالي هذا همم يمثل قدرات دوله عظمى
وهنا هي الرساله انكم حتى وان ارسلتم
باتريوت الذي لم يصل بعد الاوكرانيا نحن
قادرون على ضرب تويوتا وما هو اقوى من
باتريوت حتى قادرون على مواجهاتكم ربما
ومن هنا الافضل ان نجلس نجد احل الى اي
مدى سيقتنع الغرب بمثل هذه ال- ال- ال-
الرؤيه الروسيه هم يرون انه حتى نحاول
بوتين ان يظهر قدرات روسيا العسكريه لكن
على الارض هناك اخطاء تورته كامله طليق
جيش الروسي كالقصف الاوكراني الاخيره الذي
سقط فيه همم بعد لحظات من بدايه العام
الجديد اكثر من 80 جندي روسي هناك اخطاء
ارتكبت من قبل القياده الروسيه تجميع كل
هذا العدد من الجنود في مكان واحد بالقرب
من مخزون للاسلحه ومن ما زاد الانفجار
وهؤلاء الجنود استخدموا هواتفهم في خطا
يعني معروف تماما انه يجب تجنبه كل هذه
يوحي بان الروس حتى الان لم يتعلموا ولم
يحسنوا من اخطائهم في الماضي كما كان
متوقع ربما الامور تختلف في المرحله مقبره
لكن حتى الان ما يراه الامريكيون ان الروس
مساعدون للذهاب بعيدا وربما ربما يؤثر هذا
على طريقتهم للتعاطي مع الملف في المرحله